welcome back this week the House of
Lords will start two days of debate on
the EU withdrawal bill joining me from
fair to say opposite sides of the brexit
debate by the same side of the chamber
unless result me a lot Tim belt lovely
to see both this morning how bad is it
going to be at Lourdes bill as soon as
it gets to the house of life it won't be
particularly bad it's a very open debate
it's a piece of legislation which the
government wants to pass it wants it to
be as good as possible so to listen to a
members never listen to argue it's gonna
be plain sailing then I presume for the
government well I don't think it will be
plain sailing for the government but I
hope that the government will listen to
the genuine concerns expressed from all
sides of the House of Lords about what
we are going to be able to achieve for
the future constitutional status of the
UK and the legal framework which we are
heading to it's a weight exactly do your
objections lie people continually talk
and the committees in the House of Lords
have mentioned this in a number of
occasions but it's the Henry the
eighth's power switch which many people
see most exercised by I think that is
one of the big issues you know the
country that we live in has always been
a parliamentary democracy where
Parliament is sovereign and Parliament
is meant to scrutinize and approve
legislation that will affect the country
it is not a country where the executive
a small group of ministers is allowed to
just take decisions on major pieces of
legislation whether it's primary or
secondary legislation and override
parliamentary scrutiny so that's
certainly one issue there are other
issues as well such as you know what
powers you give to the devolved
administration's and what happens to the
border in Northern Ireland those types
of issues a meaningful vote for
Parliament which is related to the whole
area of parliamentary sovereignty I
think will come under significant
scrutiny across the house I mean it does
strike me that there are some fairly
fundamental differences of opinion in
the House of Lords Lebel and and given
the makeup given the balance
it's going to be very difficult for the
government to provision vision of brexit
as a country Stanley chamber it's very
very heavily in that durational but
that's not the point
this isn't a political debate it's not
about whether we stay or go there's been
a referendum and it heard in favor of
going and that's the position room and
so that's what we'll do but this is a
piece of legislation the purpose of
which is to make sure the statute book
is correct and therefore it's not 100%
accurate it's got me it needs
improvement even Kier Stalin said that
at the end of the debate third reading
that there was a better bill and it's
worth remembering in the House of Lords
isn't elected and it it's been passed in
the House of Commons 247 Labour MPs
voted against it without any author and
if idea whatsoever and it was passed
third reading and and this is second
really as it happens the convention in
the house is that there's not normally a
division that second reading so there
probably won't be any division there may
be odd division the Liberal Democrats
make a fast they always do but we don't
know what their position is I mean it
certainly does sound like the committee
in the report studies where things are
going to are going to get very very very
difficult but do you understand though
the position of some of the leading
brexit ears in the law chamber that if
the bill comes back any drastically
different for me but a significantly
different form it will be a failure of
the houses of parliament to deliver on
the will of the people
no I think it's a failure a failure of
the to deliver the will of the people if
it disagrees with the House of Commons
do you understand that view as well and
ban assault the idea that a decision was
taken in June 2016 which essentially
gave the government's the nod to leave
the European Union and then gave them
the freedom to decide what that exit
from the European Union should look like
not the House of Lords but the but the
government absolutely that a role of the
House of Lords is not to override the
Commons the constitutional role of the
House of Lords
is to scrutinize and advise if
legislation needs in their view some
significant change or or even minor
change you know we have in the House of
Lords the leading judges in our you know
entire legal system the British people
voted in 2016 to leave the EU and
Parliament has respected that decision
by triggering article 50 and is now in
the process of trying to deliver what
those people who voted leave voted for
what were they promised can we deliver
it how can we do that that is the
process that girls have arrived at an
answer because I could really do with
what about what the kind of the
consensus view of the British public is
when it comes to leaving the European
Union I mean surely at the heart of it
is the idea of divergence that we can go
in a different direction to the European
Union and what we're healing from
amongst others the Chancellor doesn't
doesn't suggest that that's the path
that he wants taken well I think what
the Chancellor is doing is continuing to
respect the result of the referendum
which promised people a lot more money
for the NHS 350 million pounds a week
perhaps which promised them that it
would be very very easy to negotiate new
trade deals it promised that we would
all be better off it promised that there
wouldn't be changes to the Northern
Ireland border there were lots of
promises made which people who voted
leave voted on the basis of now what the
Chancellor is saying is if we want to
deliver as much as possible of what the
leave side promised the British people
then we need to go in a particular
direction the British people did not
give us a blank cheque to do whatever we
liked the parliamentary democracy that
we're in has respected the vote of the
referendum it is trigger it is it has
triggered article 50 and is now
negotiating with the EU and what we are
trying to do is make sure that we don't
just have brexit at all costs
we have a brexit that will be in the
national interest and that will deliver
for the British people what the majority
of them voted for wouldn't a soft brexit
where we have continued regulatory
alignment in a number of areas with the
European Union where we continue to be
under the ECJ yoke workers rights are
enshrined in UK law is that the bricks
at the Union visit I don't know it's not
it's not voted for we do about the House
of Lords now the House of Lords has a
power of scrutiny and it was scrutinized
and it will debate and discuss and it'll
come to pass amendments it is not fast
movements some of those amendments will
be passed later on by the house cons
some of them will be rejected it's an on
contentious bill whilst we have both of
you once again we have allegations being
laid at the door of members of the upper
and lower house about access and being
paid for are we at a stage yet where we
can we can legitimately ask but what
benefit there is to the political system
by having our elected and unelected
representatives able to seek employment
out sight of their main job well
inevitably they have to pay for their
Dovie and they choose to do other - to
do the story in sunday times is rubbish
it's just drivel drivel it's a [ __ ]
ridiculous overstatement it isn't it's
offensive and it's just a piece of
monsters drivel overstated piece of
nonsense I think it is really important
that members of parliament are seen to
uphold the highest standards in public
life that they are an example to others
I haven't seen the programme one just
sees allegations I think that my
experience is the majority in in the
House of Lords and in the House of
Commons are decent law-abiding people
who respect the position that they have
been given by the British people or by
the British constitution but I would
just like to remind everyone that the
bill going through the House of Lords at
the moment is not about frustrating
brexit what this bill is about is about
protecting the constitutional integrity
and legal framework for our future and
it's really important that it isn't
painted as if Lords are trying to
frustrate the will of the people because
that is not what is happening we are
trying to work in the national interest
and advise MPs who ultimately cannot be
overridden the House of Lords is a
secondary chamber the primary decision
must rests with the elected House of
Commons funny games for political
journalists of course at baños almond
lovely to see thanks for coming in